my power rankings that we post every
tuesday right around lunchtime and uh
chris there's a new sheriff in town the
49ers held the top spot for all of one
week but when you lose you can't remain
number one sorry 49ers you got to slide
down the list number one this week
moving up two spots after
not
giving in to the temptation to
potentially beat down to overlook an
opponent they had no let down against
the bengals the baltimore ravens
destroyed cincinnati
and they're now number one followed by
the seahawks at number two who bump up
three spots after winning against the
49ers in santa clara the patriots move
up a spot without playing the 49ers fall
to number four saints hit five packers
pick up a spot to number six the vikings
jump back into the top ten after somehow
beating the cowboys at night the texans
are number eight up number
one spot up number one spot up one spot
from number nine chiefs are down one to
number nine and the bill's barely
holding on to their spot in the top ten
at uh at number 10 dropping four spots
after losing to cleveland all right go
ahead go ahead you've been waiting well
you've been waiting a whole day to rip
me i'm okay with number one i hear you
there that that's not that's not my
first issue so i'm i'm all for that now
where i will go is i think the patriots
should be in front of the seahawks i
think you're being a little recent bias
there i think you are just i mean the
patriots lost on the road monday night
football got in a hole were driving to
make the game very very interesting and
julian edelman fumbled to where i think
i would still give them the edge over
the seahawks to be the number two team
there that would be my first discrepancy
was there any thought of that from you
there was some thought of it yeah i
hated to move the patriots all the way
from four to two without playing that's
what i hated to do okay and and you know
what you know what if the patriots beat
the eagles in impressive fashion on
sunday
maybe the patriots jump to two and the
seahawks fall to three even though the
seahawks aren't playing this weekend the
patriots have an opportunity yes to get
to number two heck they have an
opportunity to get to number one because
if they win
and the ravens lose to the texans i
could jump the patriots right over the
seahawks and put them back at number one
yeah i get that you're yeah okay that's
good that's good to hear certainly
because you know i look at the patriots
one loss on the road sunday night
football to a team that was off their
bye week juiced up ready to go
and i still want to say hey the seahawks
they lost two home games this year you
know the so that's that's the only thing
but either way monday night they were
phenomenal so i can i can understand
your logic totally there the other one
as we get down into the top ten i am a
little surprised with you
and the bills you know the bills would
be a team as much as you know i'm a fan
of josh allen i still think he's got
great potential there
defense hasn't looked as good lately
like i might have put the steelers and
eagles in front of the bills i might
have put both of them in front of the
bills and knock them down uh because
you've said it a lot they really haven't
beat anybody this year and i know that's
not their job you know they just have to
play the teams on their schedule
but when they've had to play a team that
has some talent uh and and somewhat of a
threat to lose they seem to lose that
game so uh i'm just i'm i'm just don't
think the bills are as good as the
steelers or eagles and let's not forget
the eagles went up to buffalo and beat
them 31-13
yeah but here's the thing the bills have
six wins in nine games and i don't care
about the quality of the opponent if you
win six out of your first nine you're
six and three that's the line of
demarcation there's nobody with six wins
below number 10 and nobody with five
wins or fewer above number 10 i think
having those six wins in nine games
means something whether or not they hold
number 10 we'll see they're trending
down i already dropped them four spots
the opportunity is there for these other
teams to jump the bills but every team
below them really the next eight all
have five wins i get you i hear it just
shows you how clustered up the middle
let's move on to the next ten then the
st the steelers are 11 at five and four
they moved up four spots after beating
the rams the eagles bumped up a spot
even though they didn't play from 13 to
12. the raiders moved up four to number
13. the cowboys down three to number 14
rams down 5-15
titans up 5-16 after knocking off the
chiefs panthers down 3-17 colts dropped
two to number 18. jaguars hold steady at
19. bears bump up three spots to number
20. and again the first eight teams in
the second ten all have five wins the
jaguars have four and the bears have
four so you know there's a and
there's a there's a middle class of
teams chris where one of those teams is
going to find the gas pedal and mash it
yes right statistically one of them is
going to do it and thrust themselves
into the upper reaches of the nfl after
thanksgiving and into december and maybe
it's i of all those teams i'd say the
most likely to do it is the steelers or
the eagles okay yeah and i'm still not
going to throw the raiders out of that
conversation because they seem to have
found kind of the gas pedal already to
where you're going okay it's not pretty
but they have some formula and they can
dominate the line of scrimmage in the
run game and you know they're tough and
they do some things that you like to
where they would be one of those teams i
put in the conversation too
i do think i'd put the eagles in front
of the steelers that's the one thing i
look at there you know the eagles with
being healthy
and i'm with you mike i mean if i have
to pick one team out of all of them i'm
i'm probably going to go with the eagles
to find the gas pedal because why i mean
they've proven two years in a row that
they can take their foot off the gas and
reapply and be a quality football team
let alone like i said they've they've
gotten healthy here the last few weeks
fletcher cox is back to being fletcher
cox a guy who was dealing with a foot
injury and everything during training
camp i really think it affected him
early in the year to where he was good
but he wasn't being the mess to play up
f the play up type of guy game wrecker
and what i've seen on film from him the
two games prior to the bye week was uh
oh watch out fletcher cox is back and
he's throwing people all over the place
again so i'm with you with the eagles
there but you know after you get into
that it's just like
gosh the teams are so so many question
marks about so many of them it's
unbelievable i would have probably put
the 17 panthers
over the rams and titans right now i do
think they're playing better football
they actually in my opinion outplayed
green bay last week in green bay they
just kind of messed up the game and just
with fumble snap at the 50-yard line
that gave green bay a short field they
scored a touchdown of course they were
going into score kyle allen do an
interception there and then had the goal
line stand on the last play of the game
to where they can go in and maybe have
an opportunity to tie the game i
probably would have the panthers a few
places up uh but
you know i i get it the rams the rams
are the one where i just go oh i don't
know i mean i know they're five and four
but
whoo it doesn't look good their defense
is gonna happen no no and last week you
praised me for putting them at number
ten yeah for trusting that the arrow was
pointing up yeah and of course you
thought the rams don't you thought the
rams were gonna win i know last week no
i can't i can't wait to do the mega pix
joint podcast tomorrow i i've been
counting the minutes
for our chance to to revisit our
performance from last week thank you
yes i know you've been counting the
minutes because you've only posted the
five picks we disagreed on on social
media what 12 times 20 times with your
little green check marks well i have to
update with it with the results every
time a game ends you have to update with
the results you got the check marks oh
wait i mean i got the check mark yeah
you got the check mark well what's
amazing let me let me say one let me say
one thing about the eagles yeah and the
difference between the eagles and the
steelers okay and when we talk about
putting the foot on the gas the eagles
have a lot better opportunity in front
of them because they're tied with the
cowboys the steelers are two games back
in the loss column against the ravens
they've got work to do now
again remember this browns bengals
browns are the next three games for the
steelers if the steelers win those three
games and that's not a gimme by any
stretch especially with the browns
playing better
if they win those three games though all
the steelers have to do is be within one
game of the ravens going into week 17
that makes week 17 an afc north
championship game and i was talking
about this earlier on the radio side
chris we could have at least two maybe
more
division championship games week 17 it
could be 49ers seahawks in the nfc west
ravens steelers in the afc north and
when you look at the configuration of
the afc south those teams play each
other week 17. one of those two games
could be for the division championship
or maybe both how they interact because
those teams are so tightly packed but
there could be a lot to still be
determined in recent years
a lot of the playoff spots are already
determined by week 17 and the division
championships are known by then
we could have
a very crazy and hectic day week 17
trying to figure out these spots and for
some of them it could be the difference
like we said yesterday between the one
seed and the five seed or the six seed
if you win or lose that game yeah
definitely and unlike in the afc unlike
the nfc you know
like the eagles cowboys where they're at
it's looking like they're going to have
to win the division they're not going to
get in as the 5 or 16 in the wild card
you know the steelers like you said they
win the next three games you know the
the big thing is i don't think that
there's a chance they don't have to win
their division they still might be the
five or six seed with teams like buffalo
who's you know kind of showing some
chinks in the armor and the oakland
raiders and the colts and all those
teams who you know we have question
marks about all of them really so uh
it's not one of those with the steelers
where like they have to win the division
to get in the playoffs i think there's
still a very real chance they can end up
being a five or six seed even if
baltimore does continue to dominate and
uh win the afc north
all right let's check the box with a
quick review of the final 12 teams in
the power rankings this week the
chargers are at 21 down three broncos
hold steady at 22. brown's up 3-23 lions
dropped 4-24 the bucks even though they
won they don't move up they don't move
down they're at 25 the cardinals drop 2
to 26 after losing at tampa bay falcons
up 2-27 dolphins hold steady at 28 i
know they won but i don't know where you
put them
you can't shoot them up the 20s they're
two and seven jets are 29 at two and
seven giants fall to 30. washington's
still at 31 and the bengals a distant 32
the only winless team still in the nfl
and we're really getting closer to the
point where we have to ask ourselves
will the bengals win a game this year
you know two other teams have gone on 16
so it doesn't have that same panic that
it has had in the past but hey the state
of ohio may be able to claim a pair of
oh and 16 teams just in the past few
years it looks scary and it looks crappy
and that's the only way i can say yeah
they're they're in trouble of flirting
with oh and 16. i think there's a very
real possibility there and the dolphins
somebody's got to tell them they're
supposed to be tanking they're supposed
to be tanking that group is crazy down
there they're not going to tank you know
brian flores all them i mean hey again
you got to remember like four years from
now he's fired nobody's gonna go well oh
he was deliberately losing games and
week in the first year of his contract
to tank nobody's gonna give him the
credit of that they're gonna win games
because it goes on your gravestone at
the end of the day and i just give the
dolphins credit for fighting
and continuing to fight you know the
last four games they played some decent
football
but once you know it's done
there really is an incentive to go ahead
and let nature take its course and be as
bad as you can be if you know you're
going to be back next year because it
enhances your opportunity to get the
best possible picks and i think that's
what the bengals are in right now they
didn't start the season with the
intention of going into free fall mode
but now that they are they're just
embracing it ryan finley at quarterback
they'll probably you know they're not
rushing aj green back let's go ahead and
be as bad as we can be because that's
going to set us up to get that first
over michael's got to rebrand they got
to rebrand change the uniforms change
the helmet change everything it's just a
bad stigma around it re-brand bangles go
back to the drawing board yeah wow yeah
everything changed the name too well no
they can beat the bengals i mean there's
no bangles in the state of ohio so i
don't really love the name so i wouldn't
be mad of it but i mean yeah i think
they need to just redo it all i do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports